[Música]
hola soy santiago lópez gonzález
bienvenidos a kobe 19 la semana en
américa el espacio de france 24 el que
hacemos un resumen de las noticias más
destacadas relacionadas con la pandemia
de kobe 19 en nuestro continente a
continuación algunos de los temas que
trataremos en este programa
hablaremos del regreso de las
restricciones como el uso del tapabocas
en eeuu una decisión que se une también
a ese pedido del presidente joe biden de
imponer la vacunación para algunos
funcionarios públicos hablaremos del
interminable debate de la tercera dosis
un tema que abordaremos con nuestra
corresponsal en uruguay que va a ser el
primer país en américa latina que dijo
que ya está dispuesto a aplicarla y
ofrecerla para un sector de su población
y el gobierno de españa' impuso
restricciones puntuales a los ciudadanos
colombianos después de que identificarán
que muchos de ellos estaban ingresando
al territorio español con pruebas de pcr
fraudulentas toda una polémica entre
madrid y bogotá pues vamos a comenzar en
eeuu y lo hacemos con cifras veamos cómo
está el panorama en este país
norteamericano
eeuu cierra la semana con más de 34.7
millones de casos confirmados más de 612
mil personas han perdido la vida en eeuu
desde que comenzó la crisis sanitaria
hasta ahora el 49% de la población ya ha
recibido el esquema completo de la
vacuna
y la incidencia de la variante delta que
es la que está causando más problemas en
este momento alcanza ya el 92 punto 54%
del total de las secuencias de contagio
que han sido analizadas en las últimas
dos semanas vale la pena esa precisión
en eeuu el aumento de contagios por
cuenta de la variante delta como ya les
decía llevó a que los centros de control
y de prevención de enfermedades
recomendaron nuevamente el uso de la
mascarilla en algunas zonas de alta
circulación del virus particularmente en
espacios cerrados el porte de
mascarillas es un tema que no ha
escapado de la politización y de los
choques entre los republicanos y los
demócratas veamos
regresa la atención al capitolio esta
vez por cuenta de un viejo debate que ha
vuelto a la primera plana el porte de
mascarillas los centros de control y
prevención de enfermedades recomiendan
portarlas incluso a aquellos que han
sido vacunados cuando se encuentran en
espacios cerrados la mayoría demócrata
de la cámara baja impuso el uso de las
mascarillas en el recinto una decisión
de rechazada por los republicanos
estamos vacunados no somos un poco de
contagio pero nos obligan a llevar
mascarilla no en el senado pero si en la
cámara esto se trata de un mayor control
esto es sólo el comienzo porque las
escuelas van a volver a funcionar y las
van a cerrar de nuevo y se trata de
control base monos en la ciencia los
comentarios del líder de la minoría
republicana de la cámara y llevaron a
nancy pelosi a referirse a él como un
imbécil según los centros de control y
prevención de enfermedades el 67 por
ciento de los condados de eeuu tienen
altas tasas de transmisión del virus lo
que ha llevado al presidente by the end
a insistir en la necesidad de la
vacunación
no descartar imponer que las inyecciones
sean obligatorias para empleados
federales algunos estados se han
adelantado como por ejemplo nueva york
que requerirá vacunas a los empleados
estatales además de ofrecer incentivos a
los ciudadanos when you get your first 2
al recibir la primera dosis contra el
coronavirus taxi
al recibir la primera dosis recibirá un
incentivo de 100 dólares one hundred
down 100 dólares para cualquier
neoyorquino que acuda a un centro de la
ciudad para vacunarse bucks nate más de
160 millones de personas han sido
completamente vacunadas en eeuu aunque
la vacunación sigue siendo eficaz contra
la variante delta nuevos datos
científicos indican que incluso los
individuos vacunados pueden ser
contagiosos
vamos a profundizar en este tema hasta
con nosotros cristóbal vázquez el
corresponsal de france 24 en la ciudad
de washington
hola a cristóbal y comienzo por
preguntarle algo que me llama mucho la
atención y es que en un país tan
riguroso a la hora de proteger las
libertades ciudadanas ahora vemos al
presidente joe biden ordenando que los
funcionarios públicos tienen que
vacunarse es obligatorio pero tiene
algunas especificaciones de acuerdo al
caso que dicen así las autoridades
si trabajadores federales de eeuu están
obligados a firmar un documento que
demuestre que están vacunados en contra
de él como bit de lo contrario tendrán
que aferrarse a estas nuevas medidas de
porte de máscara hacerse además una
prueba cada semana y respetar el
distanciamiento social en sus oficinas
en otras palabras bailén quiere hacer
todo mucho más complicado para los
trabajadores federales que no quieran
ponerse la vacuna contra el cob y el
gobierno estadounidense y recordemos
emplea directamente a 4 millones de
personas aproximadamente y cerca de 7
millones más son contratadas o trabajan
para empresas que contratan el gobierno
la medida también está dirigida a
incentivar el sector privado a que el
sector privado tome medidas parecidas de
hecho united airlines y el banco de
inversiones goldman sachs ya está
pidiendo prueba de vacunación a los
nuevos empleados
cristóbal lo mencionábamos en el reporte
previo a esta conexión ahora en eeuu
deberán también usar el tapabocas
nuevamente después de tener unos meses
en que no era obligatorio la vacunación
ha desacelerado a nivel nacional que
dicen sobre este tema las autoridades
la casa blanca con el visto bueno del
centro de control y prevención de
enfermedades de eeuu había quitado la
medida de porte de máscaras en mayo de
este año pero debido a la resistencia de
una parte considerable de los
estadounidenses más de tendencia
conservadora vacunarse y el rápido
aumento de contagios de la variable
delta bailén indicó que el porte de
máscaras vuelve a ser obligatorio los
eran condados que tengan más de 50
infecciones por 100.000 habitantes en
una semana es decir más del 60 por
ciento de los condados en eeuu la medida
ya había sido tomada en otras ciudades
como los ángeles y se aplicará solamente
en espacios cerrados o de mucho flujo
público medida que algunos cuestionan
pueda ser efectiva o no teniendo en
cuenta que estamos en pleno verano y que
la gente ya estaba acostumbrándose a la
normalidad después del cob y cristóbal
ahora quiero preguntarle puntualmente
por esa orden ejecutiva que emitió el
gobernador del estado de texas en el sur
del país el gobernador greg abbott que
autoriza a la policía de este estado
y también a detener vehículos no
solamente personas en donde ellos crean
que van pasajeros que tienen aspecto
físico que les lleve a pensar que son
latinos porque piensan que estas
personas están esparciendo el virus del
cobi 19 en este estado que dicen las
autoridades allí sobre esta ley
ejecutiva y como ha sido recibido por
los ciudadanos esta orden
de esta medida adoptada por el
gobernador de texas hombre de hecho muy
cercano a donald trump es perfilar
racialmente a los latinos así lo
califica domingo garcía que es
presidente de la organización nula que
que defiende los derechos de los latinos
en eeuu esta medida adoptada por el
gobernador greg abbott se aplica en todo
el estado de texas y no permitirá que
ninguna persona ayude a los latinos que
están siendo requisados por la policía
migratoria solo por parecerse
precisamente latino hay que mencionar
que aunque resulte polémica esta medida
ya se está aplicando en todos los
estados fronterizos donde la policía
migratoria bajo la medida una medida
adoptada por aldo no son llamada el
título 42 puede ya detener expulsar
inmediatamente a inmigrantes latinos del
país con el pretexto de prevención
frente al kobe y sin tener que pasar por
el debido proceso
cristóbal muchas gracias por este
reporte desde la capital de eeuu la
ciudad de washington vamos a seguir en
ese país norteamericano para conocer
algunas reacciones y también la
situación que se está presentando en
otras áreas de la unión americana por
eso vamos hasta miami con anthony belchí
para conocer más detalles a anthony
gracias por acompañarnos hoy en el
programa y comencemos por las reacciones
que han generado estas medidas impuestas
por el gobierno federal en la ciudad de
washington que cristóbal no se estaba
explicando hace unos minutos
pues sí hola santiago lo cierto es que
independientemente de las medidas que la
casa blanca ha anunciado para frenar el
brote del virus y especialmente de la
variante delta en el país algunas
ciudades y estados ya se habían
adelantado y habían puesto algunas
medidas restrictivas conscientes de las
graves consecuencias que esto puede
acarrear sobre todo porque podríamos
estar prácticamente en la casilla de
salida del inicio de la pandemia y
porque de nuevo los hospitales en
algunos lugares podrían alcanzar el
límite de su capacidad si no se actúa a
tiempo la ciudad de nueva york o el
estado de california han celebrado las
medidas anti cobit del gobierno federal
aunque ahí ya se está obligando a sus
empleados públicos a vacunarse o por el
contrario deben someterse a pruebas
regulares de el coronavirus mientras que
en florida que es el estado donde se
están dando más casos de la variante
delta no se ha puesto ninguna
restricción su gobernador el republicano
ron de santis dice que son los propios
floridanos los que deben decidir cómo
quieren vivir si usar mascarillas o
vacunarse que no ha de ser el gobierno
el que tome esas decisiones por ellos
antonio importante ver el caso del
estado de florida porque ustedes ya lo
decía se está presentando un aumento de
casos precisamente por la variante delta
y también hay un leve descenso en el
número de personas vacunadas diarias y
en el número de personas vacunadas a lo
largo del mes de junio también cómo está
el panorama en el resto de estados sobre
todo en esos estados críticos como
california que lo veíamos haciendo
frente a un pico de contagio hace unas
cuantas semanas
si el ritmo de vacunación aquí en
florida y en el resto de eeuu y va a un
ritmo muy bueno hasta prácticamente
mediados de abril cuando ya se abrió la
puerta a inocular a otros grupos
poblacionales más jóvenes en el estado
del sol las vacunas se administran ahora
a un ritmo mucho más lento y poco más de
la mitad de la población un 51,3 por
ciento no se ha vacunado es la misma
tendencia que hay en toda la nación
según datos oficiales el 49,9 por ciento
de la población se ha vacunado una cifra
que dista mucho de la promesa que hizo
joe biden que dijo que por el 4 de julio
el 70% de la población se habría
vacunado el problema dicen los expertos
no es que no haya vacunas sino que es la
desconfianza por esta medicina contra el
coronavirus por eso desde la casa
blanca- piden impulsar programas para
incentivar la vacunación entre la
población pero al mismo tiempo también
se pide la colaboración de las grandes
plataformas de medios sociales como
facebook twitter instagram para frenar
las campañas de desinformación sobre las
dosis contra la cob y de 19 desde la
casa blanca aseguran que las noticias
falsas sobre efectos secundarios de las
dosis que no tienen ninguna base
científica están haciendo un flaco favor
para combatir la pandemia convencer a
las personas para que se vacunen no ha
sido tarea fácil sobre todo en eeuu
hablemos ahora del panorama general cómo
está la situación en cuanto al número de
contagios personas fallecidas y también
las personas que están hospitalizadas y
las zonas más críticas ya habíamos dado
algunas cifras globales para el cierre
de la semana pero cómo está el panorama
general
si de hecho los funcionarios de los
centros para el control y prevención de
enfermedades de eeuu admiten estar muy
preocupados porque las cosas se ven
mucho más parecidas al principio de la
pandemia los casos están aumentando en
todo el país ya se están empezando a
posponer eventos públicos y están
volviendo las restricciones de nuevo
como hemos visto esta semana con la
recomendación de ponerse en mascarilla
en espacios interiores y exteriores sin
importar si uno tiene o no la vacuna el
problema de nuevo es que hay una gran
parte de la población que se niega a
ponerse la dosis por lo que si eso no se
consigue advierten los expertos
sanitarios
este escenario pandémico se prolongaría
en el tiempo mucho más de lo que se
había pronosticado en un principio a
pesar de estas perspectivas hay algo
positivo la economía de eeuu que ha
mejorado sustancialmente ya ha superado
su nivel de antes de la pandemia
antonio y muchas gracias por este
completo reporte desde miami en el sur
del estado de la florida dándonos
detalles de la situación allí vamos a
ver entonces algunas cifras vamos a ver
cómo avanza la pandemia de kobe 19 en
nuestro continente para el cierre de
esta semana veamos algunos países que
fueron elegidos al azar y comenzamos en
el norte en canadá este país tiene más
de 1.4 millones de casos confirmados y
ya más de 26 mil personas han fallecido
en canadá en méxico las autoridades
mexicanas reportan más de 2.8 millones
de casos para el cierre de esta semana y
239 mil personas han perdido la vida nos
vamos ahora sobre américa ecuador
contabiliza un poco más de 485 mil casos
confirmados 31 mil personas han
fallecido terminamos con brasil
este es el gigante suramericano 19.8
millones de casos y más de 554 mil
personas han fallecido en este país
suramericano
y cada vez son más los países que están
optando por una medida como la del paseo
pasaporte sanitario en nuestro
continente la ciudad de nueva york ha
comenzado a exigir un pase sanitario a
los trabajadores del sector salud
también en la provincia de buenos aires
en argentina van a comenzar a exigir un
documento similar veamos
el pase sanitario se extiende por el
mundo en francia ya es ley la exigencia
del documento que certifica que una
persona ha sido vacunada tiene una
prueba negativa o se ha recuperado hace
poco de la enfermedad para entrar a
varios lugares algunos consideran que
atenta contra las libertades y la
libertad no existe sin responsabilidad
la libertad en la que no le debo nada a
nadie no existe es ficción es una
mentira que la gente se dice a sí misma
mi libertad solo termina donde la
libertad del otro empieza pero sobre
todas las cosas todo se basa en un
sentido de reciprocidad sin embargo este
tipo de medida no es exclusiva del país
galo en italia el 6 de agosto se
empezará a exigir un pase similar para
poder entrar a restaurantes liceos y
estadios también en israel comenzaron a
aplicar medidas parecidas desde marzo de
2021 el objetivo es el mismo incentivar
la vacunación
las regulaciones ya llegaron a américa
donde el alcalde de la ciudad
estadounidense de nueva york bill de
blasio anunció que la vacunación será
obligatoria para los trabajadores de
hospitales públicos y funcionarios del
ayuntamiento venideros necesitamos un
acercamiento claro y cada uno de
nuestros trabajadores se tendrá que
vacunar o hacerse una prueba de kobe
cada semana workers caster wild bill en
argentina el gobernador de la provincia
de buenos aires axel kiciloff había
comunicado que a partir del 26 de julio
entraría en vigor el pase sanitario que
permitiría el aumento del aforo en
lugares como restaurantes para personas
vacunadas si bien la medida aún no ha
sido aprobada es una iniciativa para
contrarrestar el aumento de los casos de
coi 19 por las nuevas variantes del
virus
cada vez son más los países que optan
por una medida como el pase sanitario
era lo que les estábamos comentando hace
algunos minutos pero también algunos
ciudadanos franceses en el exterior
precisamente que no tienen ese tipo de
pases sanitarios han tenido problemas
para poder regresar al territorio
francés e incluso la unión de ciudadanos
franceses en el extranjero envía una
carta al ministro de exteriores de ese
país ya ni leo julián expresando estas
dificultades porque por ser extranjeros
en otros países pues no se pueden
vacunar o no pueden acceder a las
vacunas que están autorizadas en la
unión europea y esto les dificulta
regresar a su país de origen
y cómo avanza la vacunación en el
continente americano tenemos un vistazo
a las cifras para el cierre de esta
semana hemos escogido países o
territorios al azar estas cifras
corresponden al porcentaje de la
población que ya ha recibido el esquema
de vacunación completo vamos a comenzar
con aruba esta isla neerlandesa ya ha
vacunado el 60 punto 46 por ciento de la
población no muy lejos de allí otro
territorio neerlandés curazao la cifra
alcanzará el 49 puntos 91 por ciento de
la población colombia cierra esta semana
con el 23 punto 11 por ciento de la
población con la vacuna completa
argentina llega al 14 punto 45 por
ciento y finalizamos con perú que llega
al 14 punto 26 por ciento de la
vacunación completa con todo el esquema
completo
vamos a ir ahora hasta la república
oriental del uruguay hubo noticias muy
destacadas esta semana anuncios muy
importantes por parte de las autoridades
en torno a la tercera dosis ya la
posibilidad de abrir las fronteras del
país para el turismo de vacunas tal y
como lo hizo ya eeuu
karina de almas está en punta del este
en el departamento de maldonado y nos
tiene más información canina comencemos
hablando por el tema de la tercera dosis
las autoridades uruguayas ya dijeron que
tienen la capacidad de garantizar está
tercera dosis y que sea ofrecida más
información al respecto porque será para
un segmento específico de la población
el ministerio de salud pública de
uruguay anunció que las personas que ya
recibieron la vacuna contra el
coronavirus del laboratorio sinovac
podrán recibir una tercera dosis esta
vez y laboratorio facer a partir de
agosto hubo largas jornadas de debate
entre los científicos que asesoran al
gobierno en relación a la medida no
porque se creyera que hubiera algún tipo
de riesgo a la salud de las personas
sino que se debatía sobre la eficacia o
no para generar mayor inmunidad
la medida se toma en momentos en que la
variante delta ya ingresó a uruguay si
bien todos los casos con esta variante
están siendo seguidos
epidemiológicamente el ministerio
anunció que las personas podrán recibir
esta tercer dosis del laboratorio facer
luego de haberse vacunado hace 90 días
con la vacuna sin novak y que las
personas inmunodeprimidas tendrán
prioridad
karina también fue comentado a lo largo
de la semana a que uruguay podría
levantar las restricciones abrir las
fronteras y permitir el turismo de
vacunas tal y como lo hizo ya eeuu que
las personas van gastan dinero reactivar
la economía y se inoculan
si bien el presidente de uruguay luis
lacalle pou indicó que las fronteras
podrían abrirse a partir de la primavera
siempre y cuando la situación sanitaria
lo permita desde la secretaria de
turismo han sido más optimistas el
subsecretario de turismo remontó un
sello indicó que esto podría ocurrir a
partir del primero de septiembre sin
embargo se están analizando varias
opciones en relación al denominado
turismo de vacunas todavía no hay nada
implementado al respecto las autoridades
señalan que primero todos los uruguayos
deberían de estar vacunados y luego se
podría utilizar parte de la vacunación
ociosa para realizar inmunización de
extranjeros esto no se está analizando
para poder estimular una de las
industrias más afectadas por la pandemia
como es el turismo y las autoridades del
gobierno también lo ven como un respaldo
solidario a los países de la región que
vienen más atrasados en la vacunación
dentro de sus países
karim hablemos ahora del panorama
general en cuanto a casos confirmados
hospitales
y fallecidos hay en uruguay
santiago uruguay desde el 13 de junio ya
no está su mapa pintado de rojo en el
índice de hardware dos de los
departamentos ya están en verde uno en
naranja y el resto está en amarillo
actualmente casi el 70% de la población
ya ha recibido al menos una dosis de la
vacuna contra el coronavirus esto hace
que el país sea el quinto en el mundo en
tener mayor porcentaje de su población
vacunada
también los casos de ingresos a los
centros de tratamiento intensivo y los
fallecimientos vienen descendiendo
durante el último mes en forma sostenida
en este momento las autoridades
sanitarias también están prestando
especial énfasis en los casos de las
personas recuperadas a que al menos el
10% de éstas está sufriendo de síndromes
denominados post cobit con problemas
crónicos de salud
karina gracias por este reporte desde la
ciudad de punta del este ya cuidarse de
esa ola de frío que está llegando allí a
uruguay también al sur de brasil vamos
ahora hasta haití en el caribe un país
en donde la inestabilidad política ha
dificultado la gestión de la lucha
contra la pandemia de kobe 19 los
hospitales están saturados al falta de
recursos para atender a los pacientes
con síntomas graves y recientemente
comenzaron a ser aplicadas las primeras
dosis de vacunas
la crisis sanitaria desatada por la
pandemia de kobe 19 avanza en haití el
país más pobre de américa donde la
convulsa situación política agravada por
el magnicidio del presidente moix
dificulta el funcionamiento de la
administración y el acceso a los
recursos sanitarios a las afueras de la
capital puerto príncipe el personal del
hospital sanlúcar lamenta además que la
población sólo acuda al médico cuando su
situación es extremadamente grave lo que
colapsa los escasos medios disponibles a
veces tenemos 60 pacientes en el
hospital que necesitan oxígeno y sólo
tenemos ies tanques de oxígeno
disponibles las áreas donde podríamos
conseguir oxígeno son inaccesibles es
una situación muy estresante para
nosotros en el hospital
los datos oficiales revelan 20.000
contagios y 537 muertes desde el inicio
de la pandemia en un país de casi 12
millones de habitantes
el personal sanitario considera que las
cifras no representan la realidad debido
a la falta de tests sin embargo
constatan la baja mortalidad causada por
el virus
debemos tener de las tasas de contagios
más altas del mundo seguro
pero los haitianos son fuertes por sus
condiciones de vida resisten mejor a las
infecciones que otras personas el
hospital sanlu que empezará a inocular
en los próximos días las 500.000 dosis
donadas por estados unidos a través del
mecanismo kóvacs según las últimas
cifras del 27 de julio ni un 1% de la
población ha recibido la pauta completa
de vacunación
en colombia esta semana fue detectado el
primer caso de la variante delta se suma
también a en este país un escándalo que
surgió en cuanto a unas pruebas de pcr
falsas por parte de viajeros colombianos
que llegaron al territorio español vamos
a conocer más detalles desde la
redacción de france 24 allí en bogotá la
capital colombiana está mi compañera
marina colorado que nos va a dar más
detalles de el panorama a lo largo de la
semana
marina debutando en el programa en la
noche de hoy gracias por acompañarnos y
destacado esta semana en colombia el
hallazgo de ese primer caso confirmado
de una persona portadora de la variante
delta que dicen allí las autoridades
sí pues como bien dices esta semana el
gobierno de colombia confirmó el primer
caso de la variante delta en el país
según las autoridades se trata de una
persona que reside en la ciudad de cali
y que hacía unas semanas había viajado a
eeuu por motivos familiares al volver a
colombia presentó síntomas y fue puesto
en aislamiento la detección de este
primer caso de la variante delta en
colombia llega cuando el país
aparentemente comienza a salir poco a
poco del tercer pico de contagios que
dejó en sus peores días hasta 600
muertos diarios las buenas noticias son
que por ahora y según el instituto
nacional de salud no hay transmisión
comunitaria de la variante delta en
colombia actualmente las variantes de
mayor circulación en el país son la
variante alfa detectada en reino unido-
y la gama que fue detectada en brásil
marina yo no puedo dejar de preguntarle
por ese escándalo que desataron unos
ciudadanos colombianos que llegaron a
españa y que en un acto de máxima
irresponsabilidad
llegaron contagiados con kobe 19 y con
unas pruebas de pcr fraudulentas que han
comentado allí las autoridades en
colombia a raíz de este escándalo que
comenzó en madrid
si la denuncia la hizo luis guillermo
plata el embajador de colombia ante el
gobierno de españa' plata dijo que en
los últimos días las autoridades del
país europeo habían detectado a 105
viajeros colombianos con kobe 19 pero
que habían ingresado al país con una
prueba pcr falsificada al principio las
autoridades españolas pensaron que se
trataba de un problema de mala calidad
de los procedimientos de los
laboratorios colombianos a la hora de
hacer estas pruebas sin embargo los más
de 100 positivos registrados que
contaban con pcr negativa hicieron
saltar las alarmas a partir de ahí
españa decidió investigar a los
supuestos laboratorios clínicos y se
pudo determinar que los certificados
eran fraudulentos además las autoridades
investigan otros casos que involucran a
ciudadanos españoles que también habrían
llegado al país europeo con pruebas
falsas a raíz de este hallazgo desde el
27 de julio los ciudadanos colombianos
no pueden ingresar a españa para hacer
turismo sin embargo los colombianos y
los estudiantes con visado de larga
duración
al acceder al país además de los
cónyuges o parejas de hecho de estos
ciudadanos españoles sin embargo tendrán
que cumplir con una cuarentena de 10
días que podría reducirse a 7 si a la
semana de haber llegado obtienen una
prueba pcr con resultado negativo marina
y para el cierre de esta conexión el
gobierno colombiano indicó que estaba
pensando en hacer unos ajustes a una
aplicación que habían diseñado para
hacer seguimiento a los casos de kobe 19
para que esto funcione como una especie
de pasaporte que le permita al ciudadano
certificar que ya está vacunado contra
el kobe 19
pues dentro de las nuevas medidas
adoptadas por el gobierno colombiano
anunciadas recientemente está la de
hacer uso de la ya existente aplicación
corona up inicialmente estaba diseñada
para vuelos dentro de colombia y para
hacer seguimiento a casos de contagio
pero ahora servirá además como un
pasaporte digital con información sobre
la vacunación de cada ciudadano además
de ser usada para otros servicios
ligados con la atención del cobi 19 de
esta manera los ciudadanos podrán
certificar si ya cuentan con una dosis
de la vacuna si tienen el esquema
completo de vacunación o si la persona
ya ha padecido el coronavirus esta
aplicación sería una de las medidas que
estaría tomando el gobierno colombiano
de cara a una posible cuarta ola de
contagios que podría comenzar a finales
del mes de septiembre o comienzos del
mes de octubre porque como ya dijimos
antes del país ya registra la presencia
de la variante delta y por otro lado
porque las cifras de vacunación totales
aún son bajas y pese a que el país
experimenta un descenso en el número de
casos y fallecidos la experiencia en
otros países muestra que una vez
vacunadas las personas a veces se
relajan con las medidas de autocuidado
lo que podría llevar a un nuevo
marina pues muchas gracias por este
completo informe desde la redacción de
france 24 en la ciudad de bogotá en
colombia estamos inicio ahora a la
consulta con nuestro doctor de carlos
eduardo pérez el médico infectólogo ya
asesor científico de france 24 está con
nosotros para comentar diferentes temas
que tenemos en la agenda doctor
bienvenido como siempre un gusto y
retomemos el tema del debate de la
tercera dosis mencionamos ahora el caso
de uruguay
estamos hablando específicamente de la
tercera dosis de la vacuna de facer y de
la de sinovac que se hecha en china un
debate que no termina si o no esta
tercera dosis
la evidencia actual santiago estamos
hablando que y desde el principio la
vacunación que va a ser necesario un
refuerzo es muy probable que la
vacunación después de seis meses o seis
meses requiere un refuerzo y sin embargo
esta pauta está establecida en pacientes
que tienen ninguno compromiso como lo
hacen en israel y estamos atentos a la
evaluación de la seguridad para poderla
implementar secuencialmente en los
países
doctor hablemos ahora de ese estudio que
avanza en rusia por parte del instituto
gamma leia que está estudiando hacer una
combinación de la vacuna que ellos han
desarrollado las public bay que es de
doble vector ellos pretenden usar el
primer vector de esta vacuna y en la
segunda dosis no aplicar el segundo
vector que ellos han desarrollado sino
la vacuna desarrollada por astrazéneca y
que tal parece que los resultados han
sido exitosos que comentan sobre este
estudio en la comunidad científica y
médica
hay varios estudios que se llaman de
vacunación heteróloga es decir combinar
diferentes vacunas hay una que está
haciendo el primero hasta séneca y luego
pzifer que se está implementando en
algunos países de europa y esta es por
el adenovirus que usa el sputnik en la
primera dosis s la de 5 y en la de 26 es
la segunda dosis es el que utiliza la
vacuna de astrazéneca entonces esta
combinación de estos 2 adenovirus se
está evaluando para verificar si esa
eficacia se puede incrementar es muy
probable que esta vacunación heteróloga
tengamos más evidencia en los próximos
meses y es abre la oportunidad para
tener diferentes casas farmacéuticas por
las combinadas y así aumentar la
cobertura de vacunación la información
que tenemos es que segura y que
probablemente si se incremente la
efectividad de la vacuna
bueno pues podríamos estar a semanas
antes de dar inicio a una posible
vacunación con dos dosis de vacunas
diferentes de diferentes fabricantes
podría ser una ayuda para inmunizar a
las personas
preguntar por un tema que hemos tratado
ya en otros programas de kobe 19 la
semana en américa pero que es equipos
recibiendo preguntas por parte de los
televidentes sobre la vacunación en
personas que ya han padecido el kobe 19
muchos preguntan cuánto deben esperar
algunos tienen miedo de inocularse
porque creen que van a revivir el virus
y van a volver a tener otras semanas de
enfermedad o que incluso van a estar
padeciendo los efectos de la vacuna pero
potenciados porque su cuerpo pues ya
tiene el virus en el interior
es una excelente pregunta porque nos
permite romper un mito vacunarse en una
persona recupera de kobe no produce
mayor enfermedad aquí la discusión es y
produce beneficios es decir vacunarse
ante después de recuperar el coi no lo
va a enfermar de coi ni le va a dar
síntomas por el coito ni nada por el
estilo es si es efectivo no algunos
estudios han mostrado que los
anticuerpos después de que una persona
se ha recuperado el cob y duran 90 días
y que probablemente una vacunación
después de 90 días haría perpetuar ese
tipo de anticuerpos por eso en algunos
países se escoge la pauta de que las
personas recuperadas de kobe se coloquen
una vacuna después de 90 días para
buscar esa eficacia permanente pero si
se vacuna antes a los 45 días a los 30
días no pases daño en su salud no va a
deteriorar la salud probablemente
también permanezcan un anticuerpo largo
tiempo y por eso algunos países también
recomiendan hacerlo después de que el
cohete se recupere y algunos otros
países
prefieren la pauta a los 90 días pero
dos mensajes claros uno no hace daño y
la pauta de vacunarse después de 90 días
con decisiones gubernamentales para
ampliar las posiciones de vacunación
pero en ningún caso vacunarse después de
recuperar el cubit hace daño para la
salud doctor pues importante el mensaje
más claro imposible creo que primero
está la salud y pues ahí están las
vacunas para evitar volver a contagiarse
a kobe 19 o seguir presentando malestar
después de haberlo padecido muchas
personas no hemos hablado aquí quedan
padeciendo el kobe largo y todavía se
están haciendo muchos estudios sobre ese
tema doctor pérez muchas gracias por
haber estado con nosotros y haber
resuelto todas estas dudas tanto de
nosotros en la redacción como de los
televidentes en diferentes partes de
américa latina'
ahora vemos un vistazo a otras noticias
relacionadas con el kobe 19 que fueron
destacadas en redes comenzamos con este
artículo publicado en france 24 punto
com que les recomiendo que visiten
israel comienza a aplicar precisamente
la tercera dosis de la vacuna a mayores
de 60 años para frenar el avance de la
variante delta que sigue causando allí
un aumento
de casos y de hospitalizaciones vamos
ahora a hablar del secretario general de
la oea que ha dado positivo en 19 tiene
como 19 pero ha dicho que no tiene
síntomas almagro suspendió entonces su
agenda pública indicó que ya está
vacunado y que si limitara a seguir las
recomendaciones de los médicos
y esto fue todo hoy en kobe 19 la semana
en américa nos encontramos la próxima
semana la recomendación sigan usando el
tapabocas lavándose las manos y
guardando el distanciamiento social y
también sigan viendo france24 sigan con
nosotros
[Música]